benvenuti solita storia oggi nuovissime
skip roma scuola è una nuovissima escape
from a scuola dove scappare dalla
maestra pazza come sempre ammette di
ricordi prende tipo cose lasciate bel mi
piace iniziamo seminari è sempre la sua
maglietta con la pizza perché c'è fame
ecco la classe e allora sembra tutto
normale ma una maestra è un maestro così
normale non è stravolta coltello lorda è
fissato una mela non so cosa voglio fare
ho già scritto il primo giorno di scuola
senza niente il pazzo dobbiamo scappare
si siano accorti
solo scorso dobbiamo trovare un pulsante
eccolo eccolo sia aperta no
si evita gli ostacoli le matite giganti
wow
rovinatemi commenti come sempre quante
volte si scatenerà vitale se vincerò io
se vince abitare ciechi figli o per
privo l'escape subito alle si sfracella
sicuro perché qualcuno vi ha premuto il
pulsante gen allarmi antincendio ecco
perché è allagata a questa scuola vede
accadendo l'acqua si è allagato tutto
allora di qua non si può andare perché è
tutto allagato quindi andiamo per forza
di fare dobbiamo trovare la strada
giusta non è quello
spesso sono queste righe mi avete sempre
celato ma proviamo festa e ora no
ma io sento la strada non erano la
centrale l'ultima cosa da milano nella
centrale
non si possono neanche
quindi qual era altra strada centrale
vai vai vitale mi ha superato che
succede alla dice uno di questi
armadietti ci porteranno è la strada
giusta ma quale sarò io scelgo i giallo
viola quello giallo nemmeno arancione
celeste blu
allora e questa sarà questi rossi no no
no no questi dobbiamo controllare meglio
controlliamo controlliamo fare secondo
me da qui parte facciamo solo trovato
presto guarda questa ragione dentro
stiamo dentro l'armadietto
l'incasso grande meteo infatti c'è
scritto sembra che siamo in un labirinto
adesso dobbiamo trovare la via d'uscita
anche qualcun altro un altro giocatore
che buco no non si può entrare qua
allora visto neanche quando di dare
buone attenti a non perderci noi gigante
questo
io ho già perso vitale non so dove sia
ma te io continuo andare anch'io ok
forse più trovato la via d'uscita
abbiamo tirato in questo labirinto per
tipo
e difficilissimo ecco dovrebbe essere
questa
dovrebbe essere continuo si sicura mi
sembra questa qua si possa fare
ok attentamente non devi essere bisogna
mercato dalla finta qua
ma dobbiamo sappiano forza ecco vitale
più fratello no perché sono bravissimo
ormai
dove abbiamo qui time buon è stato
creato rob lowe nel 2004 nel 2006 io
dico nel 2006
[Musica]
nel 2004
sensato creato pronti come vitali
mattina rete è andato prima 2004 che ho
lasciato la scritta non pensavo che
robot esistesse da così tanti anni guida
sapevate non no quando è stato creato
questo gioco siccome le brume nuova le
ire il 2021 anche io
ma il 2021 mi ha fatto passare a me non
ha fatto portare
che strano adesso mi ha fatto posto
forse ti devi per forza sfracellare una
volta io ho creato questo gioco allora
nome sopra che se presto l'ict game
quindi lui ei
quanto fa 27 per 62
la matematica io dico 1674 corretto
buttato non tiriamo è lasciato mi piace
passato e mi piace vi porterà fortuna a
scuola quindi cliccate mi piace fa per
avere fortuna e di
metterlo
[Risate]
sì anch'io che sono schiuse l'altro su
una matita
attento
però capito che cosa è successo devi
stare molto attento devi prendere la
vita e saltare sulle gambe delle matite
e poi sui righello anche dai sbrigati è
un attimo stiamo cadendo qui dal libro
dentro un'altra labini da allora senti
io vado piano e secolarità
così non lo perde ora ho perso la vita
eccolo allora io prego questo gioca
trizio bionda e ma che sta facendo
passeremo su forse è meglio non seguire
in questi giorni la nota
ha trovato non c'era o per fortuna che
ti ho seguita abbiamo nella stanza del
direttore della scuola e moretti the ok
giochiamo al computer allora dai nas
territorio arriva e si scopre che ho
avuto questo bottone
prova a trovare le forme per aprire la
porta dobbiamo trovare queste forme poi
metterli lì questa foto il cerchio forse
gli altri erano qui cilindro che noi ma
se una una stanza segreta per il
quadrato bisogna superare questo blocco
e bellissimo che teschi province
inaspettati così centrali e c'era un
buco nel muro è trovato ecco il quadrato
attento qua sembra che qualcuno non ti è
riuscito a superare
contardo errato mi mancano altra formato
che sarà ma partiamo avere qua dentro
per trovarla
a superare
sfruttare l'ultima forma mentale che ce
la farai ma certo non ce la faccio nato
e tu riuscirai ad uscire di qua senza
essere affettata da quest'evento le boe
sono in vantaggio sfruttando
cosa devo rifare tutto daccapo davvero
sei riuscito a passare avanti sono le
grandi ok piano con calma qualcuno si
presenta
ok ho preso la formale esagono via non
illuda che ti aspetto qui si
sommano altri porti quotate perché
comunque non siano caduti un po di libri
qua bisogna evitare i libri si tipo la
solita scacchiera però con i libri
questa volta dobbiamo evitare ieri
[Risate]
il righello sono saltato sulla lava
direttamente via
si faccia il lato da un'errata di nota
una areoplanino mai
negate non riesco capitale dai tuoi fan
sfegata io credo questa parte presto un
altro labirinto
nei bagni della scuola non c'è un
allagamento e dice che siamo nei bandi
per temi e quindi vai via tu non puoi
fare ma dentro
o no non mi diranno di
no
beh allora nelle poi giovane la food è
quasi una scala no questo è per tornare
gabinetto
siamo morti tutti e due riproviamo
attento devi passare quando noi
come tutti bene che queste che pronto
sfracellando più volte di vitale no pure
io mi sto solo cercando da evitare
facciamo il tifo per te c'è un fatto
come facciamo a passare tutti c'è un
pulsante va bene ma quelli che sono dei
vermi o dei fenicotteri rosa non lo so
perché c'è una bella inter è la cassetta
scappiamo da qui ci sono dei bagni di ma
che ci fai qui devi uscire perché va
bene me ne vado vado avanti perché io mi
perdo nei labirinti di robles era facile
e che parlavano che cos'è questa cosa
devo pignetti da mangiare una zuppa blu
sembra che a qualcuno sia caduto il
caffè ha sterminato caffè ma
è accaduto tanto di caffè evitare via
preparato da van pregare devo superare
vita nei bei ricordi ti aspetto
stiamo correndo
cosa pensa di mandare più rendere più
attento perché c'è la super velocità e
membra sono ancora ecco la supervelocità
perché hanno portato qua è chiuso
mi sono sfracellato sul matitone tra
imperato no arrivo dove chi non vedo più
vitale mi sono sfracellato sto arrivando
a a
eco vitale
sembra che siamo nella classe di scienze
dice che non si possono stare lì è
però quella super velocità è più
difficile
ma pensavo si potesse saltare sotto il
banco invece no è troppo lontano allora
proviamo è passato se questi sono delle
poste si sa se ti fosse bisogno essere
la strada giusta e se il governo non ha
i capelli no scherzavo proviamo col
colore della mia maglietta propria e
giusto e allora col colore della
maglietta di vitale no aspetta perché io
non mi sono sfracellata strano questa
cosa era blu
che è successo non a far sono tornati
indietro e sono precipitata forse sì se
una giornata da qualche parte
devo andare c'è una porta aperta qui
guarda
siamo fuori
dove i mezzi dove giocavo lord c'è
ancora qualche ostacolo vediamo
proprio poi a vedere i miei altri giochi
vediamo che altri giochi titano l'acqua
ariola abbiamo fatto che dobbiamo
scappare dalla lavanderia
mi piace la lavanderia la paletta non
abbiamo fatto anche questo è avuto la
faccia
3 maggio abbiamo fatto al video ok
proviamo a scappare dall'auto lavoro
ok scriviamo da manager c'è il capo
impazzito dobbiamo scappare un reato non
riuscirei mai a scappare a mani accomuna
in mano beh veramente siamo in un
autolavaggio sembrava una fetta di pane
gigante
sulle saponette ovviamente ogni skip
roma un tema quindi se questa e
l'autolavaggio salotto ma
vitale mi ha superato sì ma premieri
strage novembre quel classico pace ha
sbrigato evitare questa volta devo sono
arrivati sono arrivato già un altro
livello ormai quale l'esterno
no sono caduto dopo ci credo che fosse
preso presso una moneta o nuova moto
sono caduto
dov'era la moneta una tela di caso di
raccogliere 8 monete se lo scrittore
hanno preso anche io
vediamo che riuscirà a raccogliere più
monete che arriverà privati in sé dice
che se ne raccoglie otto di monete
riceverai un premio wow sono felice di
vedere cosa sarà questo premio magari
una macchina perché stiamo il nostro
lavaggio
non so neanche io come ho fatto
difficilissime questa parte in genere
labyring a chi mi aspetto che aspetto mi
sono credibili non riesci a fare i
labirinti da sola io non sono lo stesso
labirinto io sono in questo siamo in un
piccolo zero per volta l'uscita vediamo
se
guarda un po chi se la gioca come
l'impressione che questa sia una di
quelle che proveniamo mangiati e poi
[Musica]
come ho fatto a sfracellarsi tutt'e due
lo stesso momento allora però volevo
dirti che lì c'è una moneta quindi
devi stare attento a non ho preso la
moneta mi abbia mangiato ti ha mangiato
prima che ti mangi si
connette mi ha mangiato non sono neanche
arrivato il brano mi sembra che siamo
stati mangiati prezzo troviamo una via
più cia ma diamo che cosa
piccioli scono questi cubi che non ho
capito che cosa sono le tonsille no sono
troppe
boh non lo so che cosa ha mangiato
ecco qua attenzione il cibo intero
perché nessuno di questi matica surobi
nessuno mastica di cuba talento tutto io
sono stato sono stato colpito dai laser
che sono all'interno di questa cosa che
non ho capito che cos'è
no
affatto
superato vitale non è giusto se i due
livelli più avanti di me
e ora se la parte preferita di vinovo ti
prego no i siti aspetta propria
bisogna saltano non riesco a superare
questo livello tranquillo poi non
riuscirei di anche ad afferrare questo
di livello sono forza vitale se lo ha
fatto anche io lo faccio ha dato come
sembra che mi abbia portato in auto
botti sul livello sembra che dopo un po
di tempo che perdi ti dice ai sei troppo
stiano portare il livello anche io mi
sono sfogato alla fine mi ha fatto
passare e devi saltare sopra le punte
verso l'altra parte dai sembra facile
con i rulli per lavorare lama ha
messo una gelata e ho salvato con i rays
parte del mio operato rata vitale mi ha
superato i benefit sollievo taggio per
carmine vitale ha un nome solo già
uscito fuori sicuramente devo evitare
questo di bambini rossi
sono imbattuto ai box flagellati sui
gradini e ora bellissimo e aspetta un
momento ma che siano moneta ma no io non
ho controllato
no non c'è niente peccato che
sei in vantaggio con le monete tu nei
due comunque il prossimo livello sarà
una parte che non ti piaceva affatto
perché che cosa succede perché no avviso
ostruito il lato perché perché bisogna
camminare sui cavi o no le altezze si sa
infatti sostenendo qua sopra
ciao ciao troppo strano vedermi avanti
così e non più indietro
abbiamo in altissima
che possa farcela tu sei riuscito a
superare questo state già giu come hai
fatto è perché io sono troppo bravi
gli ultimi un nuovo piano ecco vita ciao
ciao ciao
c'è un montone qui non aveva visto preso
allora e ora è bisogno di provare di qua
e la strada si è rotta che strano come
si è rotta forse qui abbiamo la
supervelocità prima salviamoci abbiamo
superveloci musica
ma non posso stare qua no non mi fa
entrare qua no forse decentrata e non
dati
bari dire sì o no
prima divisione vero e giusto
per monete di 8 e camper che prova piace
tanto tono giusto non serve un bene per
piacere fino a quattro case lynskey
cliccare per i nostri altri video
cliccate su quella che preferite
ciao